[Music]
the tally of death and destruction keeps
growing in the northern california
wildfires
thick clouds of ash are turning day into
night
2020 has been another record-setting
wildfire season
over the last few years wildfires have
been ranging not just in the western us
but all around the world fires in the
amazon rainforest and australia's brush
fires
are so massive that they can be seen
from space
and while fires have long been a natural
part of many forest ecosystems
higher temperatures and longer droughts
caused by climate change
are drying out forests and turning trees
into tinder
meaning that in areas like california
wildfire seasons
have become supercharged towns like
paradise california
where the 2018 campfire destroyed over
80 percent of its homes
are now grappling with how to adapt to
this new age of fire
starting from essentially the ground up
it is literally like the surface of the
moon
there two years later as a town still
works to rebuild
the local parks and recreation district
is beginning an ambitious plan
to not just restore paradise but make
sure it can better defend itself
from the next fire
city lab reporter laura bliss went to
see this first
hand so laura you just went to paradise
can you sort of explain what's it like
to be there now
it was a pretty haunting experience just
thousands and thousands of homes
literally reduced to shells kind of
gutted out foundations
it really still is this landscape of
disaster
[Music]
so i guess what what has the skill of
rebuilding been like i checked with the
city and there's been about 400 homes
that have already been reconstructed
and about 1200 that are currently
permitted
even as this kind of instinct to rebuild
is sweeping
over the town and over former residents
there are some people who are thinking a
little bit differently about what the
future of paradise
should look like one resident i spoke to
has actually gone forward with selling
her land so that
eventually it might become part of a
large green belt
encircling the city to potentially
protect it from future wildfires
and the person who's leading this
project is not a member
of city government he's actually the
manager of the paradise recreation and
parks district
my name is dan f sepp i'm the district
manager for the paradise recreation and
park district
so we provided everything from swimming
lessons to
people's first sports experience to
hosting a variety of clubs
and we've been a kind of fabric of the
community for decades
there were quite a few lessons from the
campfire for us one of them was the the
role we potentially have as a parks
district
and dan believes what the park district
can start to do is improve what's known
as the wildland urban
interface it's that line between
kind of a full-blown nature and kind of
wildland areas
and then the more developed space in
paradise that
line was very much blurred or a razor's
edge
so the idea here is that we would take
that very narrow razor sharp
wildland urban interface now and expand
expanded out in such a way that
we would have a buffer at the same time
providing these kind of extraordinary
recreational resources and opportunities
dan and the parks and recreation
district are in the very early phases of
acquiring land
in hopes of connecting them and what
would be basically a giant moat of green
space
so if the nascent plan is fully realized
thousands of acres of land
could be used for respite and play by
the residents of paradise
parks and baseball fields could also
double as future fuel breaks
for fire so areas that could be parks
they could be returned in some cases to
orchards
we're interested in ag tourism in the
area so we're trying to do is take this
idea of defensible space
around a house and expand that to the
ventile space around the community
this plant is taking shape now as
california
and all of the western u.s is on fire
already this year millions of acres have
burned
tens of thousands of people have had to
evacuate with climate change driving up
temperatures and drying out forests
there's no question that the risk of
catastrophe recurring
in communities like paradise and
paradise itself
is very very real but for dan he's
hoping that this plan can make paradise
not just a dire warning of the damage
wildfires can cause
but rather a model on how to better
protect communities in fire prone
regions
earthquakes we have major cities all up
and down the west coast
that sit in major earthquake faults
we've mitigated that
we've engineered our way into having
less danger associated with earthquakes
in major cities
and we can do the same with fire we just
haven't done it yet
this is crystal cold she's a geographer
by training
i call myself a pyro geographer because
almost all of my work over the last 15
20 years
has been across this really broad
spectrum of understanding
how humans and the environment
are affected by and interact with fire
there are a lot of different factors
that contribute to changing wildfires
but climate change is the thing that
amplifies
all of those changes so when we have a
high temperature there's a lot more heat
and that heat translates into fires
being able to burn more easily and
because
they're able to burn more easily the
conditions are drier they're able to
burn a lot hotter
and a lot faster and they're much much
more difficult for firefighters to
contain while around the country the
number of wildland fires have actually
been going down since 1990
the acres burned has at times doubled
the idea in paradise is to use what's
called a green belt to help slow the
destructiveness of future fires
green belts are a type of fuel break
right
uh green belts are of course these areas
where a lot of the understory
is removed under trees that they become
essentially
park-like grasslands this is one of the
jewels of our area this is paradise lake
this uh was a location where the fire
slowed down and stopped on its own you
can definitely see
evidence of fire through this area but
the flame lengths are relatively low on
these trees
look at all of these small trees that
were cut
these are cut before the fire so that
created a more open
understory which carried the fire less
than it would have otherwise
dan wants to use the land that they
require to create more areas that look
like this
we are going to pursue a strategy here
to these oaks that are sprouting up
make them less bushy make it less of a
brush field
over time and encourage one particular
leader out of here to grow into a tree
it's really important to note that it's
not going to be as simple as just
planting some trees and grass and hoping
for the best
fire breaks are not invulnerable to the
spread of fires
high winds especially the ones we've
seen igniting some of the fires of these
catastrophic events in the last couple
of years can carry burning embers as far
as a mile
a common misconception that people have
is that a fire break should just stop a
fire
right that's that's the definition right
it's meant to break a fire's forward
progress and it should do it all by
itself
and that's really a misconception
because that is not what the goal
of a fire break usually is it is
specifically
meant to be a safe place for
firefighters to take a stand
and try and modify fires forward
progress
as it's coming into a community
you know i keep thinking about this with
the story that pulling off this green
belt
feels like a lot for a parks and rec
district to pull off
how much does something like this cost i
think dan's back of the envelope
calculation
was that this is going to require you
know upwards of 10 million dollars
and that's not even including you know
what it's going to take to maintain all
these lands
so just to give you a sense of what this
would entail one of the sections that
dan is targeting for this green buffer
idea
is a stretch of land that runs parallel
to the feather river canyon
it's about seven miles long and about
four thousand acres in total
containing hundreds of properties about
80 percent of that area is privately
owned
so on top of the costs of acquiring the
land it's also just the time
and kind of resources that a little
parks district
may be challenged to work up to turning
these former homes
into parkland also hits on the ultra
sensitive question of plan relocation
which is this idea of government
basically coming in to
assist whole communities of people move
to an area that's safer from a climate
change perspective
and that's a really difficult question
in a community that's already been
deeply traumatized by this
catastrophic experience
you know we're absolutely of the mind we
have to be respectful of our
decisions by landowners i think the idea
is right now there's such a receptivity
to people wanting to do
some things that help the community even
if they choose to rebuild
then maybe they will provide an easement
or a permission to
have that trail that goes to the bottom
of their property that allows for fuels
reduction
protects their property in exchange for
a little bit of recreational value
i think that idea is pretty persuasive
for a lot of people in our community
another issue dan faces is that while
there is a lot of anecdotal evidence
that green belts can help
there actually isn't that much
scientific evidence that confirms their
effectiveness
one conservationist i talked to for the
story referred to green buffers is this
funny combination of common sense with
not
a lot of scientific backup but experts
say that the signs are definitely out
there that they can work
it's something that is you know not
really making it into the scientific
literature because it's been relatively
rare
we don't have the sort of rigorous
reproducible scientific process
that is often favored by scientific
journals
but the anecdotal data are very much
supportive of this i actually published
a study
last year about a series of fire breaks
and what was
essentially a green belt around the
community of montecito california
between the years of 1999 and 2017
montecito would spend over 1.6 million
dollars
on wildfire vulnerability reduction
activities
and over years they did it little by
little it's individual properties
it's along roads where they have space
to work
and when we actually went back and
looked at the satellite data
it looks a little bit like a green
necklace and in 2017
the thomas fire would put that work to
the test
the calmer conditions in santa barbara
county wednesday didn't mean
flames stopped threatening multi-million
dollar homes in montecito
this is the fifth largest fire in
california history
and when that fire hit montecito there
were winds blowing
over 60 miles an hour there were gusts
up to 72 miles an hour
and that was the last thing we had
recorded before the weather station
burned down
and when it got to that green belt
along the edge of the town it basically
did exactly what
the green belt was designed to do which
is it died down
it allowed firefighters to move in close
and work safely to put water on the edge
of the fire and actually
drop it down to the ground and put it
out
and it is one of the few cases that is
really well documented retrospectively
and spatially of a greenbelt working
well we're trying to find more of those
but
but it's a challenge
what we're talking about is an idea that
how do we live with fire in this
landscape potentially
we can serve a model on a whole bunch of
different levels
not just the parks and how to protect
the community but how do we take care of
our people
we can do all the science we want but if
people don't see how it applies to them
and how it can translate into an action
that they can actually take
then the science doesn't actually you
know become applied in any way shape or
form and we don't change
actions on the ground there's been a lot
of interest
in how we protect paradise there's
lessons here
we're far enough along that we can
demonstrate some of those lessons to
those unfortunate communities that have
suffered very similar situations
but also there's models in here that
that are going to
you know help people live better better
lives in these mountain communities
[Music]